I went from like 280 to like 325 by just
eating a ton of food.
>> I ate like 600 g of protein a day.
Like that makes sense. But 600, boy,
that's a lot. I got to tell you,
realistically, 600 g of protein, it gets
into that annoying amount to eat. We
know now that up to about a gram and a
half of protein per pound of body weight
per day has some theoretical basis as
probably growing a little bit more
muscle potentially than even a gram per
pound. Ronnie weighed about 300 lb. And
I'll say this, 600 is just not that far
off from that.
Hey folks, Dr. Dr. Mike here for Harper
Strength. Been a longtime professor of
exercise and sport science, a lifter of
weights for even longer, and an admirer
of the king, Ronnie Coleman, eight time
Mr. Olympia for arguably about as long
as those two. We've looked at a lot of
Ronnie Coleman's training. You can find
those videos all around here. But today,
we're going to do his diet. And by do
his diet, I mean I'm going to eat every
single meal that Ronnie ate for his
entire bodybuilding career all at the
same time. Oh, we have them prepped and
ready. A lot of chicken.
>> It's a lot of tens of thousands of
meals. That's what I want to see these
food challenge people do. Something
completely insane.
>> Ronnie's entire career.
>> Ronnie's entire career of eating.
>> Take that beard meets food.
>> That's right. Oh, you can eat a lot,
huh? Well, you can't eat my whole career
of food. What was that? Ronnie Coleman.
It sure was. We're going to take a look
at Ronnie's diet today. See what he was
eating and let's learn us some stuff. 3
2 1 learning.
>> You were just like an animal when it
came to obviously your training
structure, but also your food. Like you
never missed.
>> Oh, no, no, no, no.
>> You finished it no matter what.
>> Yeah. Everything was structured.
Everything was done at the same time
each and every single day.
>> Yeah. That's huge, man. If you want to
get your best physique results,
you're going to want to enhance the
precision of your execution
until you're at least checking off the
big boxes.
Making sure to eat exactly what is on
your diet. If you have the RP Diet Coach
app, you can do that real easy. Break
that plug.
>> And then you're not leaving anything to
chance. Same with your training, of
course. But can you vibe a diet pretty
well? Yeah, you can. But if you're going
to be trying to win eight Mr. Olympias,
sticking exactly to the plan is a real
good idea for two reasons. One, an
actual mechanistic effect. Like if the
diet is well structured, you're going to
get all the benefits by eating the well
structured diet. But there's another
reason, psychological. And there are two
sub reasons there. One of the
psychological reasons is when you have a
structured diet, you just save yourself
a lot of cognitive bandwidth because you
already know in advance what you're
going to be eating and you just do the
plan. You just think, "Oh, can I balance
this out? Should I eat this? Is this too
much? Is that too little?" And when you
have very little cognitive bandwidth
during prep, but just like eating what
you're supposed to is awesome. And the
other psychological benefit is one of
kind of assuredness of confidence. You
have a diet that's well planned. You're
executing it. All you have to do is do
it and you don't have to worry about am
I doing the diet right? Because if you
yolo the diet, you have good days, you
have some bad days, as the show comes up
or as your best physique is sort of
maybe taking shape, you have to wonder,
would this have been better if I had
have eaten a better diet? If you are a
machine like Ronnie Coleman and you eat
the diet you're supposed to be eating,
your cognitive bandwidth is freed up and
you can rest assured that you're doing
your very best and on mechanisms you
probably are. You know, Ronnie, just for
my personal use as far as like what
happened, how many times do you think
you cheated on your diet?
>> His biceps are too small, Scott. I can't
listen to his I don't care about his
diet. Also, his shoulders are small.
>> And he looked at me like I was nuts. And
he's like, it it never even crossed my
mind.
>> Never ever went to a restaurant when I
was back. I weighed and measured
everything.
>> Do you have to weigh and measure
everything?
No.
Because much of modern food has labels.
So if you're getting like a packet of
four chicken breasts, they'll actually
tell you on the side what each chicken
breast has in it. And so you do have to
measure everything in the sense you got
to write down your macros and your RP
diet coach app. But you might not have
to weigh everything. Uh if it says, you
know, half a scoop of Gatorade is, you
know, 15 g of carbs or something, you
put three of them shits in your shake,
that's 45 g of carbs. Does it help for
many foods, especially foods that are
not perfectly labeled portion by
portion, in order to weigh them out?
Yes. And does the importance of weighing
your food increase as you get closer and
closer to the end of your diet where you
want to be your leanest, be that ending
in a show or not? Absolutely. Yes.
>> In contest prep, I ate like 600 g of
protein a day. Ronnie didn't always do
that, but he did mess around with a few
diets uh in which he ate, I believe one
diet I saw he had 550 grams of protein a
day or something like that, 600 gram. Is
that really a good idea? And the answer
is like it's interesting to push the
pace. We know now that up to about a
gram and a half of protein per pound of
body weight per day has some theoretical
basis as probably growing a little bit
more muscle potentially or saving more
muscle in a in a prep than even a gram
per pound. The difference is small, but
to somebody like Ronnie who wants to be
his best notable Ronnie weighed about
300 lb. And so for him eating 450 to
even 500 g of protein a day is
defensible. And I'll say this, 600 is
just not that far off from that. So 600
overkill probably. Is it overkill in
some crazy way? Maybe not. Maybe not. Is
it something you have to try to do? No,
almost certainly not. The big reason is
you want to make room for plenty of
hormonally enhancing fats and insulin
driving and glycogen filling and workout
powering carbs. So don't go overkill on
your protein. I'd say the highest you
should probably go is about a gram and a
half per pound of uh body weight per
day. I'm currently eating about uh just
over 300 gram of protein daily and I
weigh about 220 lb. So that makes sense.
But 600, boy, that's a lot. I got to
tell you, realistically, 600 g of
protein, it gets into that annoying
amount to eat. Especially if you don't
use shakes, whole foods, holy crap. But
you know, you're not going to have a lot
of hunger on the diet problems if you
eat that much protein. I'll tell you
that. And for his protein sources,
what's he cutting up there, Scott? What
is that? That That's right there.
>> Yeah.
>> That's a full rotisserie chicken.
>> Full rotisserie chicken. Amazing.
>> Ronnie Coleman ate boneless turkey
breast.
>> Wrong. Boneless turkey breast. You
>> That wasn't turkey.
>> That was not turkey.
>> That's the tiniest turkey of all time.
>> That was a baby turkey.
>> Oh, they killed babies.
>> Bison burger,
lean steak.
>> I love the uh narrator in like the
Macaveli motivations, which is like
Macaveli motivation. all those like Nick
Andro vision motivation. These are like
the greatesting videos on the internet.
Mad love, mad respect. But it's so funny
when they narrate stuff that's not tough
or difficult at all with the tough or
difficult voice. Like he ate bison
burgers daily. People in Africa are
like, "I'm sorry, what's that?" Like,
"Oh, it's an incredibly protein richch,
super tasty source of high quality
protein." Is that that's hard to do? How
is that hard to do? I can also
understand like if you do the Kai green
diet where you eat like only fish for
like and months. Okay, that sucks. But
like man, these are like super tasty
lean steak. Like how's that hard? He ate
steak and chicken and egg whites and
even real eggs every day of his diet.
This required meticulous dedication to
eating tasty, nutritious foods that are
also awesome and not hard to eat at all.
It is cool though. This kind of stuff is
good to watch when you're off season or
good old chicken breast.
Did I not just do that impression,
Scott?
>> I used to think, you know, if I'm in the
gym, God, off season, Ronnie is so
godamn big. What's up with his shoulder
arm situation there? Holy crap.
>> Working out
and
lifting as heavy as I possibly can
a certain number of reps while I'm doing
it. Then I would get big.
His physique is ridiculous.
>> Look at that puny belt.
>> Ronnie Coleman
won eight Mr. Olympias wearing a tiny
little belt like that that doesn't even
support the whole torso that digs into
his sides and that you can never find
the absolute right fit with cuz the
holes are just an inch apart. Maybe you
need the/2 in adjustment.
If Ronnie Coleman had the hyper belt by
the same fine folks that brought you
Versa Grips designed by Jared Feather
ISB Pro and I personally,
then maybe Ronnie Coleman could have won
eight and a half Mr. Olympias. Now, I
know what you're thinking. What is a
half Olympia?
I guess an Arnold maybe.
>> Yeah.
>> Ooh, that's takes away from the Arnold.
>> Takes away from the Arnold. Um, at the
very least, if you wore the hyper belt,
you wouldn't have to end up as only a
torso with shattered components, as you
can see to the right of this frame.
Scott, what's up with that torso there?
>> Damn.
>> Is that a ballistics torso?
>> Thought that was like abstract art.
>> Also, maybe Anyway, the Hyper Belt is
dope. I use it all the time for my heavy
leg training. I love it. It's designed
for hypertrophy. It fits comfortably.
It's awesome and you can order it right
now. Like
by clicking the link in the description.
Scott Ronniey's biceps look like they're
like falling off of his arms.
>> They're so pumped, too. Like all the
time he's squatting.
>> All the time he's squatting. His biceps
are pumped. Make sense of that. I I
thought that would be it, but come to
find out that size come comes from
eating.
>> I can't make sense of his physique.
>> I ate 16 ounces of protein with every
meal.
>> Yikes.
>> Always eating five or six times a day
>> and I was eating six meals a day.
>> Shit. Yeah, that makes sense, Scott. Cuz
it's like close to 100 g of protein and
he's got 600 g to eat six meals.
>> Yikes.
>> Yeah, that is tough. That is tough. Now,
Ronnie's a big boy and so he can fit
that much protein into his body. That
sounded weird, but um I guess
inspiration for the rest of us if we're
feeling not hungry to do that thing. As
soon as I start went from like 10 oz to
16 oz, that's when I start putting on
signs.
>> You eating a pound of protein a meal?
>> I'm eating a pound of protein a meal and
I'm trying everything in my power to
stuff this food. Ronnie's doing Scott
what we call in bodybuilding the slow
chew.
>> Yeah.
>> When like the fun part of the meal's
over and there's still a shitload of
chicken and you're just like
>> I got a couple helpful things. If you
need to put on size, you need a crapload
of clean food, lowfat, healthy fat
sources, high carbon, high protein, and
you're having trouble cramming it down.
I have some tips. Tip number one, stop
trying to gain a pound a week and gain
half a pound a week instead. you can cut
your surplus calories by half and you'll
make amazing gains. You'll get less fat.
Some of the dumbest shit I've ever done
in my life um was eat way too much clean
food and get fat off of clean food. Cuz
if you guys think about it, there's just
no winning that one. You suffered for
longer and you got fatter. That's
really, really, really stupid. Another
thing within the context of keeping the
macros the same, you have two big
upsides you can use. One is cooking
slashflavoring your food better.
You can air fry stuff, you can grill
stuff, and spices and seasonings,
especially in the off season, are
typically totally fine. They do not
alter your calories or macros. So
instead of eating like plain white rice
and boiled chicken breast and hating it,
you can eat seasoned rice and grilled
chicken, which is also seasoned, and be
having the time of your life and be
hungry for every meal because you love
what you're eating so much. The food
palletability reward hypothesis is the
idea that says the tastier your food is,
the more of it you can eat and the more
of it you want to eat. And the less
tasty it is, the less of it you want to
eat and the, you know, less of it you
end up eating. When you're dieting for a
show, your food is going to be blander
and less tasty so that you don't eat
your own hand trying to get hungry. If
you're bulking up and you have to stuff
yourself, make your food tasty. Tip
number two for bulking has helped me a
ton and it is consuming non-nutritive
sweetener drinks with my food. For some
reason, chicken and rice goes chicken
and rice chicken and rice goes down much
easier when you have like diet orange
soda or crystal light or the Mio drink
helpers and like just without plain
water. By the way, these things are
totally fine for your health. They're
neutral for your health. But for some
reason, something nice and sweet and
tangy and fruity flavored lets the meat
and potatoes part of your meal go down
much easier and it just works out for
the better. So, it's hardcore to stuff
yourself and it's super hardcore to
suffer. But to be honest, the more you
can enjoy the game, the least you can
suffer and still hit your macros and
nutrients right and still hit your heart
training, the more of a fun time you're
going to have and the better you will be
at the sport.
>> And it was the hardest thing ever trying
to stuff all this food down. And it took
me a good 3 months to do it, but I
finally did it. I went from my 280 to
like 325
by just eating a ton of food. Is it true
that one out of every five of our
channel members who also get amazing
benefits like extra long version of this
video and tons of other bonus nerdy
content will get Ronnie Coleman's exact
diet for the 2003 Mr. Olympia shipped to
them in our new sweep stakes? No. But
will you still get all those other
benefits I was talking about? But if you
become a channel member and subscribe
and link the description or whatever,
hit the button. Yes, that's true. All
right, Mike. Good job, buddy. Back to
the video. I had about six meals a day.
>> It's kind of hard to eat like that.
>> What is that?
>> Uh I think he uh
>> cream of rice.
>> Was he uh No, it was grits.
>> Grits.
>> Grits. And then he melted cheese into
it. American cheese.
>> Cheesy grits.
So, I would have to wake up in the
middle of the night to eat and go back
to sleep.
>> A lot of people don't know this, but I
didn't really eat any vegetables when I
was dieting.
>> And your blood work was perfect.
>> My
>> Dude, you're a freak, man.
>> I like that, Ryan. Oh, yeah. My blood
work is great.
Eating vegetables is incredibly amazing
for your health in about 100 ways that
they've measured and probably hundreds
they have yet to measure. Vegetables
include fiber, which is amazing for your
health. Fiber also slows the digestion
rate of food down and gets you full so
that on a fat loss diet, you're not as
hungry. Vegetables have a crapload of
vitamins, crapload of minerals, and a
crapload of phytochemicals, which are
specific plant chemicals that have
usually a ton of little tiny health
effects that do absolutely add up. So,
for almost everyone, eating a bunch of
veggies when you're fat loss dieting and
almost every meal is a really, really,
really great idea. Do as the king
inspires you to do. You don't
necessarily need to do exactly as the
king did.
>> Why did you avoid veggies? You just
didn't like them.
>> I just didn't like the way they taste.
They were awful.
>> Yeah.
>> Grits.
>> I like that all the talk about hardcore
dedication, but then excising an entire
food group is just didn't like how it
tasted. Uh we're all real people. Um eat
your veggies, folks. It's a real swell
idea.
>> You see me big up there like that, but
you know, it took a long time for me to
get there. Now, that didn't happen
overnight. I put on about between 5 and
10 lbs of muscle a year.
>> 5 and 10 lbs of muscle a year on drugs,
training full-time, eating full-time.
Patience is huge in this game. I've
tried to balloon up to massive body
weights quickly, like 10 times in my
life. Mostly what I got was just being
grotesqually fat. It's just never worth
it. It just doesn't work. So if you can
gain for 16 or 12 to 20 weeks at a time,
gain half a pound, take a little break,
maintain for a month or two at that
weight, and then take 1 to two months to
lose about a pound per week. Repeating
that cycle over and over is probably
what's going to get you to your biggest.
And that means you gain maybe 5 or 10
pounds of muscle per year. That's a
shitload of muscle in the real world.
Ideas about how much weight you're going
to gain on your next cycle are bullshit
compared to actual execution. When you
try this approach, it's going to work.
So remember, the long haul is the thing
that works.
>> 60% It's Officer Ronnie. Did he just
spit chicken back out?
>> Well, that's nasty.
>> Is from the food.
30%
is from the workout.
and the rest is everything else.
>> That lady has a very difficult job.
>> So, she's actually interviewed in one of
these videos and she was like, I have to
press on Ronnie so hard, harder than
anyone else. She's like, I couldn't do
another client after him if I had to.
Holy crap. She's like, I need a She's
like, I need a break.
>> Last client of the day.
>> Damn. I'm used to getting a different
kind of massage in which I get
overwhelmed. The RP Hypertrophy app
removes all uncertainty and makes the
training process precisely defined.
Choose your pre-made workout plan from
dozens available in the app. Plug in
your weights and the app takes care of
the rest for months of productive
training. Ready? Click on the link in
the description of this video to get
started.
>> 5 and 1/2 weeks out from Mr. Olympia.
>> God, Ronnie said that so many times. I'd
like to see somebody else drink egg
white 5 and 1/2 weeks out from Miss
Olympia. I'll probably end up after the
day is over with with close to 200 gram
maybe for the day. This is what I call
my low carb week. I probably have like
six days
where I low carb and I have one day
where I carb up real high. And I'll do
that all the way up to the Olympia.
We just basically just just monitor it
and go by how I look.
>> Yeah. What does that mean? That means
that over the course of multiple days of
low carbohydrate and thus low calorie
dieting, Ronnie's losing a bunch of fat,
but he's accumulating body water from
the stress and accumulating fatigue. And
at some point, he's not looking any
better. His body fat starts to come off
much slower. The fatigue starts to
escalate and it affects his workouts. So
the coaches will reintroduce high
carbohydrates for sometimes a day,
sometimes a few days, higher calories
that'll refill the muscle glycogen
stores, replicate what happens close to
the peak of the show so you can learn
how many carbs really hits the spot
well, how much sodium, how much fluid,
so you really know what to do for show
week, but also it recharges your
muscles. It recharges the body. It cools
off the body's kind of fight orflight
mechanism. And then it ends up being
like, okay, now we do another multiple
days of low carbs until you're really
kind of, you know, really at your wit's
end. And then you recycle back up again.
That pulsatile low, low, low, low, high,
low, low, low, high. That approach is
almost universal in bodybuilding
coaching because it's based on real
physiology and it actually works. All
right, I'm currently dieting for fat
loss and that video made me really
hungry. Ronnie Coleman's rating today is
Big Dogs Got to Eat out of Chicken
Breast.
See you guys later.
Well, that was fun. But uh I thought Doc
Mike got cancelled last year. What the
hell is YouTube talking about me?
Anyway, King Ronnie out right here. You
can watch me probably me again.
as a western culture.